A famous organization came up with five negotiating tips.
Tip number one is never discuss final terms before the end of the negotiations.
You need to get to know your opponent first, and learn about the situation.
The second tip concerns parameters.
You need to find out how far the other person is willing to go and what their limits are,...
...so that you can formulate a proposal.
Number three: Be completely clear about your own needs and wants...
...and in that sense, prepare yourself before the meeting.
Tip number four concerns reasonable parameters.
Find out about a general range,...
...compare what different companies offer, and talk to others.
If you look unprepared or even aggressive, you will lose out.
The point for tip five is timing.
Don't let discussions go on and on,...
...but be conscious of the right time to come to a close.